según todas las apariencias es el hombre
que encabeza el asalto de Rusia a la
ciudad de ucraniana de
bakmuthy dirige al grupo paramilitar
periodo Wagner y en los últimos días ha
dicho que sus tropas tenían
prácticamente rodeada la ciudad pero que
estaban siendo privadas de munición
prigó sin cuestionó si el retraso en el
suministro de municiones era solo
burocracia ordinaria o una traición del
kremlin y dijo que a su representante se
le había negado el acceso al cuartel
general militar de Rusia
en un video publicado el viernes aseguró
que no podía ver más en juego
ahora todo el frente se derrumbará hoy
Wagner es el pegamento que mantiene todo
Unido
abrigo sin parece preocuparle que Moscú
quiera utilizar a Wagner como posible
chivo expiatorio si Rusia sufre una
derrota en el campo de batalla y no es
la primera vez que remite contra el
kremlin el mes pasado acusó al ministro
de defensa ruso sergi de traición por
retener municiones por su parte
Moscú afirma que es absolutamente falso
que se esté privando a Wagner de
munición y el Ministerio de defensa
anunció el lunes que el propio shaygu
había visitado la ciudad de maripol
devastada por la guerra un año después
de que las fuerzas rusas la arrasaran
mientras prego sin intensifica sus
críticas al kremlin en el último mes han
surgido indicios de que Moscú quiere
cortarle las alas pero en Ucrania Wagner
está desempeñando un papel clave en la
invasión rusa tiene decenas de miles de
soldados sobre el terreno algunos
reclutados directamente de las cárceles
rusas